parlons-en de cession de cette station
spatiale internationale dont l'union un
peu sa fiche technique
mais d'abord la taille on pourrait
penser que c'est grand mais pas tant que
ça en fait c'est 110 mètres par 74 et ce
qui est encore plus impressionnant c'est
la petite taille au niveau de la surface
habitable
on parle ici de l'équivalent d'une
maison d'à peu près cinq chambres à
coucher donc c'est pas énorme
la masse totale de cette station c'est
400 tonnes et circulent à une altitude
de 400 kilomètres juste au dessus de nos
têtes d'ailleurs c'est le deuxième objet
le plus brillant après la lune donc on
peut le voir le soir en général
maintenant ce qui est fascinant aussi
c'est la vitesse avec laquelle elle est
en orbite autour de la terre on parle
ici d'une vitesse de 28 mille kilomètres
à l'heure ça c'est l'équivalent de 90
fois la vitesse de pointe d'une formule
1 ce qui est intéressant aussi de savoir
c'est que chaque jour elle en fait elle
parcourt le trajet qui sépare la terre
de la lune
seize fois donc c'est assez
impressionnant autre chose évidemment
sur cette fameuse station c'est que bon
c'est un peu comme un jeu de mécano un
conte et a semblé donc lé des panneaux
scolaires des panneaux solaires qui
permettent de la faire fonctionner et
des petits modules et puis aussi ces
fameux laboratoire donc ces espèces de
tests que qui sont faits justement par
les astronautes
on regarde par exemple comment évolue la
végétation on est on essaie de tester de
l'équipement de pointe et puis bien sûr
surtout on regarde c'est quoi l'impact
sur le corps humain
parce que là haut c'est dur apprécié -
surtout donc on essaie de voir comment
on peut utiliser ses connaissances là
pour faire des progrès peut-être un jour
aller sur mars est ce qu'on va être
capable de le faire donc c'est pour ça
qu'on travaille sur le corps humain
capable d'envoyer des astronautes sur la
station c'est parce que ronny a noté
technologie est bien représentée aussi
oui exactement il ya deux morceaux qui
sont entrés souvent utilisés on parle
bien sûr ici du fameux bras canadien qui
permet d'attraper des capsules de faire
de l'entretien de faire des réparations
aussi et il ya aussi un autre petits
robots très sophistiqués qui s'appelle
d'extraits qui est aussi un des fleurons
de l'aérospatiale canadienne
bon alors ça fait 20 ans que la station
est en orbite quel avenir maintenant
pour cette station elle continue de
fonctionner oui la question se pose
quand même parce que les cinq agences
spatiales donc on parle des américains
de l'européenne et canadien les russes
et les japonais depuis 20 ans fait ça a
coûté quand même
115 milliards de dollars alors ça
commence à vieillir il ya beaucoup
question qui se pose parce que la nasa a
déjà annoncé qu'en fait elle se retirer
du programme de la station spatiale
amérique internationale il ya peut-être
du financement encore jusque 2024 demi
le 28 mai après la grande question qui
se pose est ce qu'on privatise ou est-ce
qu'on l'ait désorbiter grande question
mais voilà merci frais non plus